I'll have a sausage McMuffin with egg and cheese.
3.17 is a bacon, egg and cheese biscuit.
The market's down this morning, so I can go pass up the 3.17 and go for the 2.95.
So, market's down.
He's worth more than 70 billion dollars...
...but he picks his breakfast based on what the market is doing.
This is why I'm not a billionaire.
I'm not getting that sausage and egg sandwich at McDonald's every morning.
That's gotta be the secret.
I'm not sure.
And I hear his wife puts the change in cups for him...
That might be.
...before he leaves the house.
You know, that really does seem to be, all kidding aside,...
...like a commonality among some of these wildly successful genius people...
...is they take these everyday tasks that some other people spend time thinking about...
...they just, kind of, have 'em taken care of. They don't have to give it any thought.
They do the same thing every day and they move on with what's important.